The world has lost 68 percent
of its wildlife populations
in under 50 years,
and there are people around the world
working to protect and grow
the wildlife that is left.
In Africa, however,
the approach to conserving this wildlife
has almost always involved
a separation of people from nature,
the involvement, but never
leadership, from local people,
and a problem statement that has often
come from outside our continent.
Basically years ago, colonial governments
decided that we, as Africans,
were not fit to take care
of our own wildlife.
And so people who had lived
alongside wildlife for generations
were removed from their ancestral lands
and called new names.
Poachers, encroachers, squatters.
The story of conservation, as a result,
has almost always then involved
only a foreign scientist
with a clipboard
or a guy in green with a gun,
there to protect that wildlife
from everyone else.
The rest of us have never
existed in this story.
And those who came to save species,
came from the outside.
And when they came,
they were labeled heroes.
They had to teach local people
how to live alongside wildlife
on the fringes of wild lands
that they used to own.
This has created two distinct problems.
One, because we don't often
tell our own stories,
it means that those
who are closest to the wildlife
are not seen as invested
in conserving that wildlife
compared to those
who've come from the outside.
And because foreign conservationists
have sometimes not taken
into consideration
the needs of local people,
they are then seen as caring more
for animal life than for human life.
If we do not change this approach
to conservation in Africa,
we will lose all of our wildlife
and with it, a part of our humanity.
I believe that the time for Africans
to define conservation ourselves has come.
(Applause)
And when Africa leads
its own conservation efforts,
we will not only restore
our wildlife populations
but our land and our cultures
and our broken relationship with nature.
Through my work with Ewaso Lions,
an organization based in northern Kenya
doing lion conservation,
I am working with a group of people
who, together we are co-designing
what that conservation could look like.
But first, a little about myself.
I grew up in a crumbling bungalow
in the heart of Nairobi,
Kenya's capital city.
Long before it was called
Nairobi by the Maasai,
the nomadic pastoralists
where I get my heritage,
they had called it a different name.
Nakusontelon.
"The beginning of all beauty."
As they would graze their cows
and goats on the banks of the river,
they would watch the evening sun
creep down the acacia trees.
That was their vision of beauty.
Centuries later, I would do the same,
I would watch the monkeys
in the giant trees,
and colorful birds would call
to each other in the morning.
In October, when the nandi flame trees
would drop the last
of their fiery orangy flowers
that we would use for hopscotch in school,
there would be thousands and thousands
of jacaranda trees in full bloom
across the city,
reminding us that it was
the start of exam season.
(Laughter)
"Have you studied?
Are you ready?"
they seemed to say.
We were just a part of nature.
It was just a fact.
And then the chainsaws came.
They cut down so much of what I loved,
they cut down my memories.
And they have kept coming
not just to my city,
but to places around the world,
and not just for trees,
but for everything.
Let me put some numbers here
so you understand what I mean.
Lions have lost 92 percent of the area
that they used to roam in Africa.
Out of a possible 100,000 lions
maybe just a century ago,
there are now only about 20,000
lions left in Africa.
And in Kenya, there are only
2,500 lions left or thereabouts.
So what do you do when
you're confronted with such loss?
The answer for me was to study.
And so at the University of Nairobi,
equipped with new zoological expertise,
I was informed that I could go out
and teach local people
how to live alongside wildlife.
Where did that thinking come from,
that I could go out
and teach people how to live?
At the University of Oxford,
I took my studies further,
and I really began to unearth
the conservation models
that had led us to this point.
And while my studies have provided a frame
with which to view what was happening,
it is really on the ground
in my country doing the work
that I have gained the most
perspective and clarity.
In the Samburu region of northern Kenya,
there's still little separation between
people and wildlife and livestock.
Here, you can still hear
the cow bells clanging
as a little boy brings his goats to water
on the mighty Ewaso Ng’iro river.
And behind him, nibbling
on the tops of trees, are giraffes.
And behind that, the rumble of elephants.
It is here that I have found a group
of people who are pushing back
on that narrative that excludes us
and tells us that we're not fit to lead
and really building true
community-led conservation.
There is so much to this approach
that I believe could be important
to form the new Kenyan
and the new African conservation.
So let me share some of those things.
First,
out with parachute conservation
and in with indigenous local leadership.
(Applause)
Parachute conservation
might be a new term for some,
but it's just that old superhero story.
You jet in, you have all the answers,
you employ a few people
to effect your solutions,
and then you leave or you never hand over.
And the world labels you a hero.
This sort of conservation
is so detrimental
because it means that local people
will forever be the helpers
or the local informants
and never the leaders
and the decision makers.
And when that happens, people lose.
And when people lose, wildlife loses.
So what's a better way?
Let me give you an example.
One of the first people to join
the Ewaso Lions project
was Jeneria Lekilelei,
a young Samburu warrior at the time,
and now a junior elder.
Now this is not some crazy thing
you wouldn't understand.
A Samburu warrior is just a young man
between the ages of 15 and 30
or thereabouts,
and it is his job to take care
of the family's livestock.
The Samburu and the Maasai
are brother tribes.
But while I have lost quite a lot
of my Maasai heritage to city life,
Jeneria still lives
a very traditional Samburu life.
And so while I was at home,
watching David Attenborough
and loving lions,
Jeneria was hating lions.
He saw them as the killers of his cows,
and it's understandable
that when a lion comes along
and takes the family cow
or the family camel,
there’s going to be anger,
and people will go out and kill lions.
But Jeneria had an idea.
He wanted to involve warriors
like himself in conservation.
He knew that these warriors
had the exact skills
to track and kill lions
every time they'd go after livestock.
He also knew that these warriors
had never been brought
to the decision-making table.
And so he brought them, and he said,
"Instead of us tracking
lions to kill them,
let us track lions and then tell
every other herder where these lions are,
so that livestock are safe
and lions are safe.
And they can share the space.”
And it is through Jeneria's
Warrior Watch program
that he has worked with these warriors
as conservation leaders,
and they have saved lions
hundreds of times in this way.
And Jeneria, as the director
of community conservation,
has worked with his community
over these years,
and the Samburu
lion population has tripled.
(Applause)
Next, let us stop merely involving women.
Women must be as much part
of the solution as men.
And if our imagination for 50 percent
of the world’s human population
ends at involvement,
we have already lost.
So women where I work demanded
to be part of conservation.
They said --
(Applause)
They did this, not just
because they saw the men,
but because they have
a historical stake in the game.
In the Samburu creation story,
wildlife belong to women.
So the story goes
that all the animals in the world
at the beginning of time
belong to the Samburu,
and they were all livestock.
The men were apparently
very good livestock keepers,
whereas the women
were terrible and irresponsible,
and they let the livestock
out of the enclosure.
And donkeys became zebras,
and camels became giraffes.
And that's how the wildlife
of the world came to be.
So these women took
this myth and they said,
"We are turning this patriarchal
myth on its head.
We are the people who own the wildlife,
and so you're doing wildlife conservation?
Then that's our business."
And one of them who said this was Munteli,
who is the coordinator
of the Mother of Lions program.
The Mama Simba program.
So Munteli said
that as part of their work
providing lion locations
and forming a home network,
that all the women, including herself,
need to be taught to read and write.
And so they were attending
class once a week.
And then Munteli came back and said,
"Actually, you know,
we have far overtaken the men.
So we have built
an enclosure in our village.
Bring your teacher and bring
your whiteboard.
We want lessons four times a week."
And so the women were learning.
And then Munteli came back and said,
"You people are not letting me do my work,
I need to reach women
in so many other villages."
And so we asked her,
"Munteli, what would you like?"
And she said, "Teach me how to drive."
Munteli is now one of the first
traditional Samburu women to drive a car.
(Applause)
In her region.
And she, after just learning
how to read and write
just a few years ago,
she texts lion locations
in three different languages.
She has proved that
the impossible is now possible.
She has expanded the room for women
to participate in conservation,
and there is room for all of them.
Conservation is about people.
I have learned that the people
who are keeping lions
roaming in Kenya today
are warriors and women
and children and elders.
They are people educated by their culture;
they are urbanites with a respect
for that culture.
And as more Africans allow co-existence
to happen in our spaces,
we will turn back the clock
on wildlife declines
and really make life better for all of us.
It is time for conservation to be broad.
Broad enough not just to include
a species in trouble,
but our land and our cultures,
our innovation, our story, us.
Who we were, who we are
and who we want to be.
Thank you.
(Applause)